[Music]
can't do hug lines because of miss rona
but are you still doing a line at all
after this or no
unfortunately we're not at the end of
these events but um
make sure you keep your tickets stubbed
because they're free and transfer why
are you a hug next time we're here oh
yeah because i brought my book and like
got a sharpie and everything so like
i'll just sign it up
for you yeah no worries oh my god you
guys are awesome i'm like i've been
following you guys for the last few
years i've been binging your podcast so
i'm on like episode 122 now
i made mine you're listening in the
wrong order i would start with now and
go backwards yeah
[Laughter]
i just showed my mom your documentary
before we got here so um
my question for you tonight
i'm such a fanboy i swear
thank you
so um
as i told you i'm wearing the minimalist
uniform i like decluttered my wardrobe i
wear like almost exclusively black
t-shirts and the occasional button-up
over that
um
some of the people very close to me who
i love very much not saying any names at
mom
who loves me very much uh
like my parents and things they
don't necessarily understand why i sort
of like the simple wardrobe and
want to
sort of help me expand my wardrobe but
um that's just not something that i'm
super into that adds value to my life
because i'm totally chill with the black
t-shirt life uh it's really just helped
me in my mental health i'm a transgender
man so it helps with my dysphoria
[Music]
um
so i was wondering how to go about that
stuff when you're 17
and uh
you're sort of starting this new
lifestyle and your parents albeit super
awesome ones who you love very much
might not totally understand the
direction you're trying to go or not
know how to best support you
wow what a beautiful question um
what kind of psycho wears all black all
the time
i agree with you mom why would you let
an emo psycho thank you very much
uh ryan why do you wear black all the
time i wear black because it's slimming
honestly
oh man i uh i i love not having to
decide what to wear when i go to put
something on i too have like a black
button up because sometimes like you
can't go to places without like having a
collared shirt on or something but you
know what's awesome about you matthew is
that
the the color of your personality is
like brighter than any color you could
wear on the outside oh shook show me
oh
matthew bring that book up we'll uh
we'll make sure we sign it yeah for sure
i owe you a hug and and i'll tell you
what your what your mom is doing like
that's the best she can do i'm bringing
you out here to come and see us i mean
that's even though she doesn't
understand it that's incredible that's a
great very amazing mother yeah matthew
you're on youtube
mom you're awesome
she understands it right now
thank you for being here thank you very
much
josh can i say something together go for
it
matthew one thing i just want to say to
you is that
because it's not over here right we just
had a beautiful moment but five years
from now 10 years from now 20 years from
now for the rest of your life you're
going to be challenged by people who
don't approve of you but people who
don't agree with you and the first thing
i want to say to you is that you don't
need to disrespect people in order to
disagree with them right when you are
non-defensive you are disarming when
someone says hey i don't like what you
do i don't see it the way you do i i
disagree with you you know one reaction
is to say well you just don't understand
and i hate you
but that posture is only gonna make you
feel more angst and it's not gonna bring
you closer to the other person you can
respond to people in a way that's
disarming by saying
i hear you
i hear you and you can leave it at that
right not always defending your point of
view isn't the same thing as affirming
the opposite and sometimes we confuse
boundary lines with battle lines but you
can establish boundaries between
yourself and other people without
engaging them in battle
look go ahead
oh
she said that he's what she wants to be
when she grows up
that's amazing that's beautiful
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel one hundred
percent advertisement free